STOPOVER IN JAPAN, CHRIS, AND HE
REFUSED TO WEIGH IN.
BACK TO YOU.
REPORTING LIVE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
KEVIN, THANK YOU.
WASHINGTON IS WAITING TONIGHT
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP TO RELEASE
THE DEMOCRATIC REBUTTAL TO THAT
REPUBLICAN MEMO, ALLEGING BIAS
IN THE FBI AND JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS HERE WITH
ALL THE DEVELOPMENTS.
GOOD EVENING, CATHERINE.
>> THANK YOU, CHRIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY
RELEASING A STATEMENT THAT THIS
AFTERNOON THE PRESIDENT MET WITH
THE FBI DIRECTOR, SENIOR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL TO GET THEIR
INPUT.
"THE PRESIDENT IS WEIGHING HIS
OPTIONS AND WILL RESPOND SOON.
EARLIER TODAY, THE OVAL OFFICE,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS ASKED ABOUT
THE DEMOCRAT’S COUNTER MEMO.
HE PROMISED DEVELOPMENT.
>> WE WILL RELEASE A LETTER
SOON.
>> AFTER MONDAY’S UNANIMOUS VOTE
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS TO MAKE THE
DEMOCRATS VERSION PUBLIC, THE
PRESIDENT HAD FIVE DAYS TO VOICE
OBJECTIONS UNDER LONG-STANDING
CORRECTIONAL RULE.
THE DEMOCRATS PERSIAN DRAFTED BY
THE RANKING DEMOCRAT ON THE
HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
ADAM SCHIFF, IS TWICE THE LENGTH
OF THE MEMBER RELEASED FRIDAY.
MULTIPLE SOURCES SAY THE
DEMOCRATS GO IN DEPTH IN SOURCES
AND METHODS THAT WILL CALL FOR
SESSIONS BEING BLACKED OUT OR
REDACTED.
AMONG THE PRESIDENT’S ACTIONS,
ASKING THEM TO REDRAFT THE MEMO,
INCLUDING SECURITY INFORMATION,
TAKING THE SAME COURSE AS THE
REPUBLICAN STAFF MEMO AND
DECLASSIFY THE DEMOCRATS VERSION
IN FULL, OR BECAUSE OF THING THE
DEMOCRAT VERSION WITH HEAVY
REDACTION.